fair warning before we get started on
this one I'm going to have to have
spoilers in here there's no way to talk
about Goblet of Fire and not bring up
the end this is a new movie I would do a
spoiler free review than the spoiler
talk but it seems a little weird to be
like spoiler free review and spoiler
talk to a movie that's a decade old dub
just get a despair warning at the end of
this gonna spoil here we go
[Music]
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
so Harry Potter in the Goblet of Fire is
Harry Potter's fourth year at Hogwarts
the Death Eaters which is a Voldemort
lackeys of Voldemort supporters they
seem to be getting a bit gutsy like
something's going down this all happens
when Hogwarts is hosting the Triwizard
Tournament that's when three schools and
all including Hogwarts go to other
schools they come to Hogwarts to take
part in this try wizard tournament
eternal glory awaits the winner of the
very dangerous Triwizard Tournament
Harry Potter is too young to compete in
the Triwizard Tournament nor does he
want to compete he doesn't want glory
and the Goblet of Fire is just his cost
at his name and of course like Harry
Potter how but it's a binding magical
contract now Harry has to compete in the
Triwizard Tournament and there's a lot
to like about this chapter in Harry
Potter's world as the kids are getting
older the characters are getting older
the story is progressing it's getting a
bit darker there are steps taken in here
things happen in here other Harry Potter
stories have not shown yet and this
gives Harry Potter the character and the
world a lot of flavor you also really
get the feeling that Harry Potter is
ill-equipped to be in here he is too
young to be in this competition yet he
is in this competition in the first
trials you don't see how the other two
competitors actually get through to see
what Harry Potter has to do when she has
to take on this dragon and steal its
golden egg and he has to outsmart this
thing it's kind of like when you're
playing an RPG or an MMO and you're
totally ill-equipped you can't handle
this boss but you have to so you try to
clip around wolves and sheep hit him or
maybe get up on a rocky your best to
kiss the egg without him actually
hitting you everyone you farm the shock
arrows and breath of the wild the first
time a lot like that but it is the perma
that you don't see how Victor Fleur and
Cedric Diggory the other competitors in
the Triwizard Tournament got through
their dragons but in the second
competition they have to go down in this
lake and retrieve a friend because they
have to hold their breath underwater for
an hour and Harry's like I don't know
how to do that this is when you really
see that Harry is ill-equipped because
Cedric Diggory I mean everyone has
bubble charms on their heads like oh
yeah bubble charm before I can breath
underwater now you get the feeling it
was no problem for the Victor Krum is a
shark but Harry had the
from someone who learned from someone
that gillyweed grow skills he had no
idea how to do this that's when you
really feel like you don't have the
spell's necessary man I've worked with
once again I love other great on a curve
the second competition Harry's like I
finished last I stuck I'm all doors like
but you know since you're swell and you
showed sportsmanship that screw it you
get a silver medal so now he's in second
place because Dumbledore says though I
call shenanigans on that like wouldn't
anyone be like that kind of fix is it as
weird as using the word shenanigans in a
sentence no whatever and we cannot talk
about this movie without talking about
the new Defense Against the Dark Arts
teacher mad-eye Moody Alastor Moody is
the best best defense against the dark
arts teacher they will ever have in
Harry Potter he's an hour he's hardcore
hours our wizards that ultimately hunt
down bad wizards they're narcs pretty
much but in the Wizard World all
sincerity gave you the spoiler alert
funny thing is he's not actually mad-eye
moody he's Barty Crouch jr. and he does
it though something and I don't know why
he really does it everything you know
about mad-eye moody says this guy is
mad-eye moody which is totally not
mad-eye moody at no point does he act
like Barty Crouch jr. so there's awesome
mad-eye moody he's supposed to be crazy
but super hardcore not actually him he's
not the guy so when you meet mad-eye
moody later on in this series you're
like I've never met you before but
everything I know about you is from the
other guy and it feels like it
translates to actually being you he does
show the three unforgivable spells
though the Imperius curse the Cruciatus
curse and the killing curse all of which
you learn about you're like yeah I'd be
pretty shouldn't do that in the wizard
world it just makes the world a bit more
real a bit more filled out the fact that
there are these curses that you're not
supposed to do you cannot do that if you
do you go right to Azkaban we all
learned about that [ __ ] whenever a movie
really flushes out the rules of the
world and the universe it just makes it
feel more alive this entire series went
on without unforgiveable forbidden
curses wouldn't be as interesting to me
but there are some tonal shifts in the
movie were like not always meshing well
I thought it was really sweet that they
have to go to the Yule Ball because
there's a tradition of the Triwizard
Tournament I like that and as someone
who was a nerd in high school it's very
much like you're like I getting a date
suck the fact that they did that makes
them one step ahead of me however run we
usually was a bit of a dick in this
movie it was to the point of unlike
ability I know they're playing up a
teenage angst thing and they are at the
age to where they need to do that Ron's
all pissed off at Harry
he feels like he's just Harry a sidekick
I do get it but it just comes across as
so petty when you're watching it you're
like - you gotta get over it and if it
were just that that would be enough but
then there's a scene where he has an
exchange with Hermione at the ball and
he completely ruins her night you're
like Ron's go away but he's just friends
so we keep them around because
friendship and friends they're very
important but for their story you look
at Ron you like you're nothing but a
hinderance in his one-man even Neville
Longbottom showed him how to breathe
underwater
even Neville who is seen as a hindrance
is a likeable hindrance who is
contributing less he is not actually a
hindrance Rogers being a pain in the ass
in here however the last trial is this
maze and the maze is super
claustrophobic I love that about the
maze you're in there you're like I don't
know should I look around quarters you
know what's going to happen you don't
know what's coming the plants are alive
deadly foliage is the scariest thing in
the history of scary things because
they're not alive until they are but in
the anger come the real spoilers in the
end of it Cedric Diggory and Harry
Potter grabbed the Triwizard cup they're
going to be champions and then it's a
portkey and they go to this graveyard
where ultimately baltimore comes back
we've seen Voldemort before in some
weird shape or form he's in the back of
a head or he's in Tom Riddle's diary but
we've never seen him come back now my
friends the Horcruxes have done their
job they've done their part his
loyalists do their part bring the dude
back Voldemort and Harry have a bit of a
showdown in the graveyard and it's a
taste of what's to come you lick the
frosting knowing that the cake and ice
cream is coming in the next movies not
before they kill the spare the spare
Cedric Diggory yeah for the first time
in a Harry Potter film a kid actually
dies kids have been in danger kids have
been petrified none have died this one
this little dude he's all shriveled
Voldemort I care this one tells us
because I bought a Cadabra fan just kill
Cedric Diggory big deal in the Harry
Potter world it is it shouldn't be
because Dumbledore says at the beginning
of the Triwizard Tournament species like
this is very dangerous you could die in
the Triwizard Tournament bit a kid dies
and it's like oh my gosh how shocking it
shouldn't be this is Hogwarts the fact
that it took this long for a kid to die
that's the baffling part Dumbledore his
speech at the beginning about this is it
just solidified if a parent was given
the choice send your kid to Hogwarts or
send your kid to predator school in
40,000 BC where they learn to take rocks
and bludgeon predators to death ensuring
a 99.9% mortality rate but
friends might survive and feast on the
carcass of the dead predator parents
really like also my kids their Hogwarts
just seems slightly more dangerous in
the end Harry just has to run he gets
the pork T get set her degrees body they
come back I love the scene where he
comes back because everyone's like hey
try with David's out everybody 130
degree second then a few people like
Cedric not moving I think he's dead and
Harry's freaking out he's crying
Dumbledore comes down there and he
starts comforting it's the scene where
Cedric Diggory dad comes down and breaks
down it gets me every time
every time I see it I just start getting
a little lip quiver like mom god I don't
like parents seeing their kids die and
you do see Dumbledore and Harry have an
exchange of sorts afterwards where it's
like Dumbledore is like I believe you
and you don't really know why yet you'll
find out later on but Dumbledore you
have to assume feels a fair amount of
guilt for the whole Voldemort thing as
Harry Potter's let's be honest if Harry
had let Remus Lupin and Sirius Black
kill Wormtail in the last movie all the
more wanting to come back Cedric Diggory
would still be alive Harry's got to live
with that now never really addressed but
he does but then after this whole speech
were Dumbledore it's like he was killed
by Baltimore at the Ministry of Magic
doesn't want me to tell you but it's
true everyone's like crying and it's sad
the next seat everyone's like all right
we're going homeless right every day how
things are going to be different now I'd
say yes
all right let's write each other it's
gonna be great summer you're like I I
guess we're over it kids dead but
whatever slip and slides aren't going to
slide themselves in the end Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire is great and it's
very watchable and rewatchable the fact
that the Triwizard Tournament is broken
up into three different trials that
makes it interesting they try a long
trial to you trial three oh [ __ ] both
boobs back in the end that's a big deal
it's exciting trials mixed with an
exciting and some of the tonal shifts in
the movie don't always land it's the
first time you really see the Harry
Potter movies dealing with what
book-to-movie translations really have
to deal with a lot and that is crushing
this many pages and that that much movie
a couple hundred pages of book fine
Harry Potter books start getting into
the few hundred pages a little harder
and I would say Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire is definitely worth
watching and worth buying on blu-ray
this is noticeably the first Harry
Potter movie without John Williams doing
the score and it totally shows I mean
the music in this movie is completely
fine and it works especially in a couple
scenes but John Williams will take the
music and make it its own character this
way you just notice that's not the case
alright guys so Harry Potter and the
oblah to fire have you seen it what did
you think about it or does it rank in
the hierarchy of the Harry Potter movies
for you I know this one's a bit divisive
among people some people love it some
people don't want to hear what you think
so whatever you think comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]